a crack den in North London where last
year we gained access to people at the
heart of a county lines operation and we
revealed how the number of known lines
to rural areas had doubled to 2000 many
of them using exploited children as
drugs mules they need money a mummy and
daddy ain't got no money so who do they
come to they come to uncle and uncle
send them out there this is what I give
to the people and the little kids and
they go out for me now a survey by the
Children's Society has found indicators
that the problem is still growing in
just three years the number of 10 to 17
year-olds arrested for intent to supply
drugs outside of London have gone up 49%
from 338 to 505 so these are young
people that forced to carry drugs inside
their own bodies the force to travel
around the country they're forced to
sell drugs and live in really squalid
conditions sometimes for weeks or months
at a time
so actually what it really shows is the
harrowing nature of this crime and it
seems to this report you're identifying
that the children are getting even
younger so we heard from some
professionals that children as young as
seven and eight are being targeted the
report authors also criticized what they
call a haphazard response from local
agencies it's prompted councils to
respond saying that government cuts have
forced them to divert money away from
children who are most vulnerable the
children Society says boys are most at
risk but one in six of the children
being exploited our girls Lucy who ran
drugs from London to Southampton aged 14
says she existed in a world of drugs and
violence I got involved with the wrong
people
met some rung older guys they were I
don't know they would more like to get
me to join drug-drug running
going missing for the whole night which
a lot of people in care do go missing
because their drug running and earning
money and you're being asked to do what
exactly
so drugs sell heroin crack cocaine
everything and where are you going to do
this where we're about to go so tonton
The Children's Society says their
figures based on police arrests are just
the tip of the iceberg and wonder how
many children are out there under the
radar
Jason Farrell Sky News